schutz vor kosmischer strahlung das
deutsche zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
hat jetzt wohl eine lösung steht einen
sicheren flug zum mars damit nichts mehr
im weg jetzt bei klick von science
fiction verfügung
ich habe hier ja darüber berichtet dass
einiges dafür spricht dass wir immer
älter werden
die nasa hatte zumindest in wien ziehen
dafür bei ihrem quillings experiment
gefunden unter dem video gab es eine
heftige diskussion darüber ob nicht die
kosmische strahlung das wiedervereinigte
machen würde oder ob nicht die
herzinfarkte an den montagen auch die
gestorben waren
dagegen sprechen würden während die
herzinfarkte bisher einzelfälle genauso
bringt wieder für links experiment der
nasa sind ist kosmische strahlung ja in
jedem fall für mich gefährlich ein wie
wer so viel strahlung war auf einer art
von auto oder einem astronauten während
seines gesamten lebens maximal zugemutet
werden für den normalen erdbewohner ist
es sogar bedeutend weniger für zukünftig
geplante bemannte marsmission gab es
erst kürzlich eine schlechte nachricht
den forschungs resultaten der university
of california in irvine zur folge
erreiche eine astronauten oder ein
astronaut die maximale strahlen grenze
von einem fieberkrampf knapp nur während
der reise zum roten planeten
damit würde während des lebens die
grenze von einem wieder deutlich
überschritten werden
ohne irgendeinen schutz kann man sich
eine reise zum mars also wohl getrost
sparen das deutsche zentrum für luft und
raumfahrt die israelische
raumfahrtagentur esa und das unternehmen
im rat haben jetzt aber wohl eine lösung
für das problem eine strahlend
schutzweste eine messinstrument programm
matroschka soll mit dieser strahlen
schussweste aus dem hause stemmert
ausgestattet werden und via orion
raumkapsel im jahr 2018 ins all
befördert werden anhand der met werke
die im zuge des fluges gesammelt werden
sollen wird man dann klären können ob
und wenn ja und wie gut eine weste den
menschlichen organismus schützen kann
ohne ist die reise zum mars ja wohl
unvorstellbar zitat hochintensive
ionisierte strahlung zerstört
knochenmark welche für die blutprodukte
um wichtig ist die folgenden schwerer
anämie infektionen und krebs
forschungen haben gezeigt dass es
ausreicht rund fünf prozent der
knochenmarkzellen zu schützen um eine
erholung und erneuerung des blutes zu
ermöglichen
das sagte der geschäftsführer von themba
doktor und mit sein
längeres leben im all das video dazu
haben wir hier verlinkt und hier könnt
ihr übrigens mir was aufs auge drücken
und denkt an die glocke und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt